je crois aussi que je je crois aussi que
le complotisme c'était aussi une manière
de mépriser le peuple de mépriser les
gens de mépriser leur capacité à se
poser des questions à penser par
eux-mêmes
je trouve que c'est très bien aussi avec
ce qui se passe autour d'eux autour de
ce documentaire que j'ai même pas vu un
d'ailleurs j'ai pas le temps de le voir
hold up mais peu importe
cette espèce de mépris de les gens vont
pas comprendre les gens les gens vont et
odeurs dans cette confusion alors que
cette confusion elle est quand même
entretenu par les médias mainstream oti
puisqu'on a des contrevérités en
permanence et ça bouge très vite et
beaucoup mais je trouve qu'il ya
vraiment cette cet écrasement des gens
on va leur dire mais ils vont pas
comprendre ils vont pas comprendre et
donc s'ils sortent du discours officiels
dominant celui qu'il faut qu'on puisse
rendre qu'on puisse avaler mais sans se
poser de questions si on les fait sortir
de ça olalala là ils vont vraiment dire
n'importe quoi et ça va prendre des
proportions qu'on va plus pouvoir gérer
c'est du mépris de classe et c'est assez
insupportable
[Musique]